(audience applauds)
It's time for Drew's News.
Your overstuffed, super-sized,
good news hoagie. (mimics chomping)
And with me at the desk, my trusty co-pilot,
Ross Matthews.
Hi everybody. Hi, hi!
HI Drew.
(audience cheers)
And the intrepid host of Inside Edition
and our dear friend of the show,
Deborah Norville.
(audience applauds)
Yay!
How crazy that we all picked blue today.
I know, it looks like we're all going to prom together.
Look at this, we all coordinate.
It's like an electric cornflower
and there's a bunch of ladies, members, guests
over in this section-
There's a blue section over here, right there.
Who we clearly got on a metaphorical telephone with
and sent out a memo.
Okay. Deborah, you are are a seasoned pro, obviously.
You've done so many hard hitting investigations.
Okay.
You are the real deal journalist here,
and we wanted to join some forces maybe,
on some crime stories today.
Great. Let's do it.
Okay. Excellent.
This is our first ever Drew Crime,
Inside Edition Special Report.
(audience applauds)
(dramatic news music)
First of all, I just have to say how excited I am.
Okay, let me stay cool,
something I've never done in my whole life.
Let me try, there's a first for everything.
Here we go.
First up,
the story everyone's talking about,
"The Tinder Swindler".
Mm-hm.
Millions have watched the Netflix documentary
about a man who allegedly conned his dates
out of hundreds of thousands of dollars
but no one heard a peep from the man behind it all.
But Deborah, you have the scoop.
Yes, we do.
His name is Simon Leviev.
Inside Edition got an exclusive interview with him
to hear his side of the story.
And here's what he has to say.
Take a look.
You don't feel bad for them in any way?
I feel bad for something that I didn't done? No.
I feel bad for what had happened to myself.
I want to clear my name.
I want to say to the world, this is not true.
He says, it's not true.
He denies all the allegations,
but boy, he seems to be capitalizing on all the attention.
He's partnered up with Cameo,-
Mm-hm.
Where you can go on the website
and you'll get a greeting from Simon for $199 a pop,
that's if it's a personal one,
if it's a business thing, he charges more for that.
He's working on a reality show, he told us.
He's working on a book,
and his model girlfriend,
she says, she's gonna stick with him.
And it gets more interesting, doesn't it?
It certainly does.
This story is still developing.
And the real diamond tycoon family is reportedly
suing Simon now, for allegedly impersonating them
and unjustly enriching himself by using their last name.
And we reached out to Simon's reps on this,
and they said, "Simon looks forward to sharing
his side of the story soon."
But this lawsuit that you mentioned is really interesting,
because the Leviev family,
and they are huge in the diamond business,
huge in the diamond business.
Now Simon's name is not Leviev,
he changed his name legally to Leviev.
He started with a last name that started with an H.
Anyway, the Leviev family filed this first lawsuit,
but they have said that the subsequent lawsuits
will go after anyone who has enriched themselves
through their association with Simon
from "The Tinder Swindler" documentary.
So what they're trying to do
is head off anybody from doing business with this guy-
Wow.
And protect their family.
It's fascinating,
because there's still more to report soon.
I can't believe you got this scoop.
I know.
Well done.
And who knows what's next?
Maybe he'll be on "Dancing With The Stars"
or something like...
Oh, you know, he will be.
(bright music)